so we're waiting for a hotel room to be
ready so we have like an hour two ways
we just had some dinner lunch breakfast
I know what time it is it's so weird I'm
really sleepy but it's really nice to be
here we're at this park just just
chillin just relax and just maximal cool
and shoot some Bowl but our hotel room
should be done soon it's a really cool
hotel it's the same one as in lost in
translation if you've seen that movie so
you know where we are then that's great
alright I'll see you there
bye hey what happened hey Alex I was
going that's great we're in the islands
in Maputo and we put in Japan I already
know that look at the view it's awesome
we're gonna go let's see if I can show
you we're gonna go there to that giant
green thing we're gonna walk there
pretty sure we're gonna die but it
should be fun white why don't you come
when we're walking to the park there's
so many people I don't know if you can
see but it's crazy
oh my god should I don't want to film
the Rhino for Japanese people don't like
the FL I don't know
yeah let's get something
like they have oh my god I want
everything the girliest drink ever so we
went to shinjuku park and it was closed
but now we found another park by
accident so we're gonna go in there
should be fun it looks at me we're
walking through this temple I'm pretty
sure I'm not allowed to vlog here but
I'm a badass anyone watching we know
okay it's really cool
we went lost and wind it up here I don't
know what's going on but we're here so
yeah this is weird cut here because we
got really really sick in Japan and I
didn't film anything for five or six
days so yeah
enjoying cool price uh it's been four
days
we're in Kyoto I got the flu
first March they got the flu and then I
got it from her and it's been pretty bad
I'm still really sick but we decided to
say two more days because we came all
this way right it's falling off um [ __ ]
people are coming so we figured it makes
no sense to go back if we haven't seen
anything but yeah I lost like five kilos
my pants don't fit me anymore because I
didn't eat anything when I was sick
oh yeah let's enjoy a kill though it's
gonna be great alright see you soon
to my stairs I'm not gonna do it fire
myself so dead we made it
it's the heaven afar I have no energy oh
my god let's look at yeah that's like
temple
there's temples everywhere here it's
crazy
whoa look at this what is this what what
what is this this is so weird
sit here that's so weird
there's your free nightmares you're
welcome oh my god what is this
look at that you can see it's too bright
there it is we're going there the red
thing cool best log ever so we just went
to Kyoto Art Museum or something
I don't know it's in there we weren't
allowed to film film film but it's there
I got nosebleed you can see it now you
can't
I got nose played on me yeah don't you
me myself who wins now I stopped myself
constantly now we're gonna go somewhere
we don't know where but some right
second my mask keeps falling off our for
a damn thing my blogs are so good which
one should we take we have that one horn
oh yeah oh my god why would you anyone
what is yeah what is wrong with everyone
okay I'm putting in mine what are these
they're super annoying what do you think
they're like I got the same is like
thank you thank you thanks sorry we're
annoying thank you okay
corn corn drink but I putting my extra
money so I could get my other nerve
well I don't know I guess it great agree
and agree oh my god it's hot yeah the
people eat it this is food
someone else is coming I looked for my I
was looking for my other glove look
where it is oh my god hey let's go over
here
hi I'm Korra pi and welcome to corn soda
this is not even like this is food
you're supposed oh that is an ASC oh God
smell it smells like hear it smell it
smells like someone you cooked the bunch
of corn and all this stuff that was
after it they just bought in a drink
yeah it's a bad it's pretty good I'm
like a tasty soon I like it it's really
good you should try it it's like don't
smelly I said do something funny so
funny thank you
let's see what's inside I don't know
what we're gonna find good oh it's
awesome
Oh what's your search
whoa that's pretty awesome
all right so we're going back home I
didn't vlog the lie say because I don't
know but it's been a pretty depressing
vlog but I hope you enjoyed it with me
and I hope you had some good times
looking at that and yeah I'll see you
around in the next one
can't wait brofist